[Music]
hello my name is George carp and I'm the
cabinet member for Community safety and
youth engagement and we've got some
really exciting news to say that we are
starting our first ever youth Council
but I thought let's start without
telling you what a couch was about
[Music]
so this is our Council chamber here we
have all our meetings committee meetings
cabinet meetings and our full Council
and this is where you if you become a
youth counselor will be sitting and
having your meetings up here behind me
we have where the chairman sits to the
left is where we have the cabinet sit
and the controlling party and then here
behind me we have where the opposition
sits and these benches behind here as
well as much as this building has seen
many different critical parties this is
your chance to come in here and voice
your opinion on the changes you want to
see happen in thanet here at broadstairs
they're renowned for having multiple
events from a food festival to folk week
but what events do you think we can do
to help engage with the younger people
across the district Ramsgate has been
successful in leveling updates and going
forward the youth council could have a
chance to have their say in what bids
look like the local area throughout
Thanos
here in birchington Westgate and garnish
there are proposals of housing
developments and it would be really good
if the young people often it had their
voices heard in terms of what those
developments look like and how they
could get onto the housing ladder in
Margate we're going through a lot of
change we've successfully got the
leveling of it and also the town deal
with
it it's great if the youth Council had
their chance to have a say on what
Margate looks like going forward for the
benefit of them across planet we have
some amazing parks and Open Spaces that
the youth council could have their
chance to say what they would like to
see in terms of equipment and ultimately
as much as this is about a chance to
have your say and to have your voice
heard this is about having fun as well
foreign
we're really excited about what this can
become the youth Council where young
people going to have their voices hurt
and a chance for them to sign up for
their local communities
if you know or you are someone that's
really interested in this then please
get involved because it'd be great to
have you on board
[Music]